we are driving to a very strange
location somewhere I have never been and
it's because of the woman in the
backseat is Diana physics girl yeah
we're gonna go get a consultation for
something very special
right now it is look I'm not gonna keep
you in suspense laser hair removal we
want to talk about the science that
makes laser hair removal work I told him
about this idea last like probably a
year ago and then I was gonna do it in
July or August and I've been waiting for
this moment yeah so now I'm good oh it
stinks yeah laser plume laser flashes
that that's the smoke that comes off No
yeah how was that shot
the laser we're using has a wavelength
of 1064 nanometers meaning it is
infrared radiation invisible to the
naked eye but without an infrared filter
the camera sensor picks up the laser
pulses which in my case were six at a
time each one lasting about 1 and 1/2
milliseconds we dialed it up a little we
dialed it up just yeah nice ready the
laser will now deliver 25 joules of
energy per square centimeter oh my god
all right whoa oh my god that is insane
might burst did you see that yeah it
looks like like a shoot out of the OK
Corral is what that looks like just
getting my slaughtered that's amazing
that is an awesome shot that's it that's
really sick
I have no idea that it was the shootout
at the okay that makes me it really kind
of reignites my excitement about my job
we get even closer on this next one
that'll be cool
so what's actually going on here well
dark eyes skin and hair contain a
molecule called melanin and melanin
absorbs a wide range of wavelengths of
light especially in the ultraviolet part
of the spectrum and this makes it an
ideal shield against the sun's harmful
rays which is why you get a tan when you
go out in the Sun that's your body
producing and releasing more melanin in
the skin but the idea with laser hair
removal is to get the melanin in dark
hairs to absorb the laser light without
the skin around it absorbing much of
that energy so it actually works best if
you have really dark hairs and light
skin infrared lasers are commonly used
because melanin absorbs in this part of
the spectrum more than other common
molecules in the skin like water and
oxyhemoglobin red lasers at 755
nanometers are also often used for the
same reason as the melanin absorbs the
laser energy the hair heats up to well
over a hundred degrees Celsius causing
it to burn and vaporizing the water it
contains and this puffs the hair up a
little bit like a Cheeto it's that
expanding water vapor looking closely at
this shot you can actually see the
bubbles on the hair from the
vaporization of water but the objective
is not to destroy the hair it's to
actually use the hair to destroy the
germ cells in the follicle that produced
the hair in the first place so it's kind
of like using the hair to kill the hair
this image shows a cross-section of
three hair follicles following a laser
hair removal treatment and the one in
the middle contained little melanin and
therefore shows no damage the other to
show the hair shaft has been destroyed
rupturing the inner root sheath and
damaging the outer root sheath cells
suffer damage when their temperature
rises above 60 degrees Celsius this is
because at that temperature the bonds in
proteins and collagen molecules start
breaking apart and that's a process
known as denaturation so the hotter it
is and the longer that temperature is
maintained the more denaturation occurs
and the higher the likelihood that that
cell will die now if you caused enough
damage to the cells in the follicle that
make the hair the hair will never grow
back and that is the goal of laser hair
removal the sequence of ultra short
pulses is
to ensure that the heat doesn't spread
too far into the region surrounding the
hair so the idea is the hair heats up
damages the germ cells right next to it
but then the laser light turns off
before that heat can spread too much
further and then you hit the hair with
another very short pulse again if you
were instead just to keep heating the
hair it would heat not only the germ
cells around it but also your skin that
you don't want to damage and you would
end up with burns so that's the reason
for the series of pulses that we saw but
if you think about it this is kind of a
weird irony I mean melanin is a molecule
meant to protect us meant to protect our
skin from a harsh rays of sunlight and
that's why it absorbs that light before
it can penetrate further into your body
and do damage but now with laser hair
removal we're using melanin its unique
absorption powers against it by
overpowering it with lots of laser
energy we get it to heat up the hair to
such high temperatures that the hair
kills the neighboring cells the germ
cells in the follicle that produced the
hair so we are Hersh are using melanin
powers against it normally before a
laser hair removal procedure the hair is
shaved and that serves a few purposes
for one thing not too much energy goes
into burning the external hair which
does you no good in the first place and
second it prevents the hot hair from
landing on the skin causing surface
burns but we found that shaved patches
were less interesting to watch because
you can't really see what's happening
under the skin after the creation of the
first working laser in 1960 its inventor
theater of meinen called it a solution
looking for a problem
an unwanted hair may just be that
problem because laser hair removal is
the most requested cosmetic procedure
hey I have a lot of people to thank who
made this video possible like Diana
physics girl whose idea this was
thanks to her I no longer have that
strange patch of hair on my shoulder so
you should really go check out her
channel a physics girl and I also want
to thank Darren without him at be on
slow motion we would never have been
able to do this he was simply amazing so
you should also check out the on slow
motion and of course I want to thank
audible the leading audiobook provider
with hundreds of thousands of titles in
all areas of literature including
fiction nonfiction and periodicals
chuckles whenever I'm out I'm on the go
and I can't really watch videos like
when I'm driving then I listen to
audible and I also listen to audible
when I'm on the plane and I'm about to
get on a plane right now and fly to fall
bard Norway which is nearly the North
Pole and that is gonna be a very long
flight so I will definitely be listening
to my audiobooks in fact the audiobook
I'm listening to at the moment is called
creativity Inc and I am learning a lot
from this book about how to be a
creative person how to be productive and
it's a great book to listen to because
it's a story told by Ed Catmull and you
kind of feel like he's there with you
telling you the story of how Pixar was
founded and how they made creativity
work so I'm loving that book if you want
to check it out you can actually
download it for free or you get a free
30-day trial by going to
audible.com/veritasium you know one of
the reasons audible keep supporting
veritasium is because they know that the
people who watch this channel like
learning things and another way to learn
things besides YouTube is to listen to
audiobooks so I highly recommend you
give them a try for a 30-day free trial
if you want to do that go to audible.com
slash veritasium thank you so much for
watching